so Ryan said people's understanding of
timeline in mind I mean you started
episode 8 while episode 7 was very much
still in production
I did yeah yeah they were still shooting
actually here in London they're still
shooting episode 7 and so yeah I think
about that today because obviously a
colin is doing the same thing where what
we were in production with episode 8 he
was starting to think about nine and
Dino
it was kind of strange because we want
the first things I did was went up to
San Francisco and spent about six weeks
kind of figuring out the story and i
would go in a few times that we can sit
down with these guys and with the story
group and just hash it through and we
would watch dailies that were coming in
from seven at that point it was just a
script and kind of the dailies that we
are seeing and I was thinking about that
i think i was it probably really healthy
that in thinking about where the story
goes next
it was entirely just based on our
reactions to it as opposed to based on
the phenomenon that it would become at
the cultural reaction to it was just a
very personal
what do we connect with about that with
these characters and and where do they
go next
i think is a good thing yeah you were
coming to understand who our new leads
or new heroes and villains where you're
coming to understand
hooray then go and kylo were just as
they were actually still coming together
yeah yeah it really was a and it was a
unique experience
so when it came to
you came aboard and I this is just a tip
for any future filmmakers a real smart
way to get your foot in the door at
Lucasfilm if you ever have a meeting
with us is to bring homemade ice cream
or our very first story meeting with
ryan is like he surprises us all by
bringing us ice cream which is like
yours we're gonna expect this man yeah
we can expect this for not only no but
what you did which I thought was really
great is we began sort of a a film camp
so to speak Ryan assembled movies that
he thought it was important for us to
watch and understand his point of view
about them so that we have this common
language and I would love for you to
share some of the titles that we watched
well it was ok i mean there was also
stuff that I really wanted to because
we're in the middle of you know the
middle coming up with what the stuff is
going to be and it was also stuff for I
thought it would be really good to
rewatch this and it's funny like at the
time so we were it was twelve O'Clock
High it was a letter never sent it was
well should we watch the watch
Bridge on the River Kwai that's right
progenitor of a quiet down screws which
one three outlaw samurai
oh that's right three outlaw samurai
that's going to watch super no wait no
we can watch Hooper
now we can i watch super separate that
was intense right now
I so hear that story we'll get to that
we'll get to that they did that
so now it but it's funny actually
watching and now being we were just at
the end of production right now and
going through and looking at the film
that we put together and looking back at
the movies like particularly twelve
o'clock high
there was a good seeing oh my god a lot
of that made it made it in there like at
the time it was just like oh this will
be kind of a fun bonding thing and maybe
there will be things here and there but
they didn't end up actually being a
really really crucial part of it watched
Gunga Din remember that and then that's
right yeah
what is that and we watch the hair and
not the matthew mcconaughey's sahara
that the Humphrey Bogart sahara worries
a tank commander and my favorite part is
like we're at Skywalker Ranch were
sitting there watching this and Ben
Burtt sticks his head in and it's quite
first question is who is watching sahara
and it made him love us
yeah go to where they are had anyone who
will dig out the heron and watch it in
the theaters got to be good people
so when we announced that episode 8 was
in production we had a little video that
we showed of you basically recreating
the scene between Mark and Daisy at
scale like so can you talk about that
yeah that was a really surreal way to
start the whole thing out so we did it
was when we started coming up with you
know I start coming with the story I
realized that I wanted to I immediately
kind even really think about that the
notion that we're gonna end up breaking
kind of a long-standing Star Wars
tradition
and for the first time this movie is
going to start right where the last one
left off because it was like I don't
want to skip ahead
that last moment of seven I want to see
what happens next and so just didn't
because of the demands of the story
that's where it ended up being which
meant we went back to the skellig and we
were only able to get a couple days of
shooting there and it was months before
we started principal photography so it
was really the first first thing that we
did and it was a very surreal and the
island itself is this amazing it feels
like you're stepping into a history it
feels like you're serious something very
mystical and magical about the islands
Rick Carter had described it to me
before I went there in his very Rick
Carter away and it's a very Rick Carter
plate it's like an incredibly mystical
place
so to be there and be that the first
thing that we're shooting is is you know
Mark and Daisy standing up on on Christ
saddle and then skellig michael and it
was just so you know it was a
appropriately surreal beginning to the
whole experience and this was before
anyone really knew like that that moment
would become so iconic to the world so
so
wow that's good baby i'm gonna need that
extra is not so paralyzed by fear
yeah let's talk about working with some
of the classic cast and you know before
we go into that I just want to
understand like what your level of of
Star Wars appreciation was going into
all this and then what it meant to have
mark hamill and and Carrie Fisher and
people like anthony daniels in front of
you and and they're yours to direct now
yeah i mean i feel like it a and then a
lot of conversations I've had just over
the past few years I feel like it it
almost you almost want to lead with an
apology like I know everyone has a this
is what star wars means to me story
this is it sounds almost easier p debate
is something that's so integral stars
was the diamond it was the
it was the first and i have this memory
of my dad putting me in the car to take
me to see Star Wars and I asked him
where are we going said we're going to
see the most amazing thing you've ever
seen and I
and and he was right and that combined
with its funny the as much as the movies
were something that I really reacted too
i think even bigger and that's why it's
fun like walking walking the floor and
like seeing like seeing that the toys &
and I don't know that that I feel like
because back when back when the movies
came out it wasn't like we had them on
our iPads like it was you had to put
your name in the waiting list of the
video store and then you got the VHS and
then you and your friends watched it for
24 hours straight
it was like you didn't actually get to
see the movie much so what you had where
those toys and I think even more than
the experience of the film the fact that
the first stories we were telling in our
heads as kids were in that universe with
those toys I think that's why I'm sure
any other like I think several people
have said when we want when I walk down
the red have the same experience of
walking on the fact Falcon set for the
first time and unexpectedly it kind of
really getting choked up out of nowhere
and what it was is flashing back to
being a kid in all the stories I told
inside my kenner in a pack of the Falcon
yeah exactly and suddenly you're
standing in it and there is just Eddie
intense emotional reaction that that
happens so anyway that's that's that's
that for the business
so now as I was saying before you you
now have Luke Skywalker and Princess
Leia and c3po and r2 and Chewbacca in
front of you with your you're rolling
camera and you're telling them what to
do i mean what's that what's that like
for you
good
well it's it was it was a very I mean
that it was an incredible experience on
many different levels ultimately though
you know in order to and this is one of
the things that
the whole process was kind of about a
comment you come into it with those
feelings of deep nostalgia but then you
realize your responsibility ultimately
is to get beyond that very quickly and
to ultimately I don't know ultimately
tell a story that you feels alive right
now and there's about where you're at
right now i guess and that I guess it
was kind of like the ultimate
responsibility of it is to sit in front
of marks in front of Luke Skywalker and
then have those feelings of them sitting
here talking to Luke Skywalker's was
kind of weird and that's it yeah and
then take to get to know Mark and get to
know him as an actor and then start
working through the script and then get
back into the actual work of filmmaking
and telling a story and the same way
that I video you do with any other film
basically you know to get to the point
where you just the and I've been
expressing this right but I'm but it was
a it was surreal all around I guess
and now a wonderful that the new cast
you've got the you know Daisy and and
John are back Oscars back
they have all kinds of atoms back
they've all had their first
oh my goodness i'm in Star Wars
experience with the last film so how did
you find them coming into this movie
they were wonderful and it was it it
you're right there was that kind of
feeling of there was a big explosion of
the first one and now the second but it
it ended up serving I think what this
second film is in a very good way
because the first film was this is this
incredible explosion of adventure and
excitement that sets up these characters
and then just out of necessity it's very
natural that the second film is where we
start
zooming in on the characters and kind of
taking them seeing ok really kind of
getting to the heart of them and
challenging them pushing them deeper and
so I think the actors were all very
excited about that
yeah
so you are one of I think the first you
are the first director who had a public
presence on social media before we
announce that you were our directors
that what I had
yea he is in addition to the traditional
bullet point under IMDb trivia for
anyone who's editing that so
so what was that like because you were
so accessible the world
to be honest the world knew before we
were even able to formally announce that
you were directing episode 8
so you must got a lot of traffic coming
your way asking that to confirm or or or
to talk about it online
yeah it's been I mean that's I've been
on
I mean I i love being a love being on
the internet i love being like I've
always loved social media even with like
my first film that I did
brick which was before Twitter it was
thank you
we said wait way back before this
Twitter existed at that i created like a
message board on my website for people
to come and talk about that I've always
really just loves being out the end and
I guess I was a little a little nervous
in terms of what what something on this
scale would do what I still be able to
enjoy it the way I had before and so far
it's it's been it's been wonderful so
far it's still been you know the same
sort of thing of just engagement with
people and you know so I don't know so
far so good it just feels kind of very
continuous we have any people here who
follow Ryan on Twitter or Instagram or
another
I apologize colleges well speaking of
Instagram you've been very generous in
sharing some photos from the set that
you yourself took during the making of
this movie
so we have some here I don't know we
could we could show him up and and see
if there's any stories to tell
this is that oh these are fantastic
background crowd who are in the who were
in the who are in the film it's funny
you
you realize you realize as you do these
films how importance
how important the background players are
and so you realize how deeply embedded
they are from the original films and you
hear head some of the background you
start paying more and more attention to
them as you're directing and we we had a
really really great crowd that the
really took to it and then gave a great
performance in the background the scenes
running black and white this looks like
you're making a . pictured here
there's a lot of and there's some shots
of and if they're in here but like Gary
our camera man when he's he kind of has
a seventies fro a little bit and when he
is behind that camera like on a dolly in
like a you know resistance hall in a
ship hallway
you look at the shot and he was like oh
that could be yeah it could be from the
seventies vehicle
let's take a look at another photo here
yeah that's
oh yeah so there I think that's Billy on
the its Billy Lori's gather they're
actually and and we actually a no for a
a lot of the stuff i posted i apologize
it a lot of it is kind of green screen
in the background and that that's an
agreement not to put down green screen
it's a great tool but died i just
haven't wanted to like give anything
away but I when I let everyone know the
amount of sets that we've built for this
movie has been absolutely outrageous and
a tremendous amount of practical sets
and we also we have the luxury of doing
things like this where we build exterior
interior sets of some of the ship so we
not only would be able to film inside
them but also do shots from the outside
that weren't just like window comps and
actually move into them so
yeah we and we we had fun
next photo please this is Ireland
so yes we've got people from Ireland
great love of Ireland's yes
ok so that yeah and the end
in addition to two sets of it a big for
curved at the trunk of the film we went
out to Ireland and actually in addition
to Skellig
we shot along the south west coast of
the west coast of Ireland had a lot of
really incredible locations and it it
was amazing getting out there a ways
into the shoot and then suddenly having
this whole other texture to the film
opened up in front of you and just the
natural beauty of that coastline and to
be able to put these actors out there
and it actually put them out and just
film it and seats this stand behind the
camera and the end and have it feel like
that it's it was it was just incredible
yeah well let's take a look at another
wonder now who's that guy knows that guy
I was very lucky to have the man in the
cowboy hat come out to visit several
times and spend some time on set and
yeah it's you just immediately feel calm
and at peace when Dave felonious
standing back behind you you feel like
everything's going to be okay and i
gotta say i mean we we talked about it a
lot but it's true we have a kathy and
carry make it
it's so accessible that any part of
lucasfilm that will benefit from being
on the set and anyone that you would
benefit from having on the set that that
communication and that you know flying
from from from one side of the world to
the other to come and help each other
out that that great that's a reality of
making Star Wars movies now
well it was nice like even the time that
talked about when wait when i was in san
francisco they're coming up with the
story
Gareth was there and they were coming up
with rogue at the same time it would be
like right down the hall they were
working on the road and you come down
and just say hi and take a look at the
whiteboard and talk through stuff and
and then dave was doing you know just
doing rebels in the same state is right
there in the presidio and it it had this
kind of campus like feel that I know
it's pretty cool cool
next photo haha yes said these helmets
man these helmets are bigger than you
think
like you see pictures of the museum on
screen and and then you see them in real
life and you're like really my god
they're like that they're massive and
also every anytime
anytime that we were shooting a scene
with these guys and helmets
i would i would start playing a daft
punk is playing in my house on my phone
really loud
I think it got annoying everyone looks
like we have anymore
yes uh-huh yes and this is actually a
photo is my assistants leo
we stuck in a TIE fighter an outfit and
and I had a lot of fun
direct directing him ruthlessly but but
it was it was it was I don't know
did this is another one of those shots
though where and there were a few of
these sets where that you know this or
some of this stuff in the falcon or the
x-wings where you put them in there and
you frame up and you'll look at the
monitor and you're just like oh my god
used to have that instance a connection
to it I guess it's pretty cool
let's see if we have any more we don't
all right now
ok it's very different yeah so I guess
you know this is probably not the best
kept secret in the world but the
production name for star wars episode 8
who here knows it
space there's their production is done i
think it was kind of a codename code and
that's right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
gotta say it had we have we all have
every one of our projects have code
names were not gonna tell you what it is
otherwise it defeats the purpose of
telling you what your name is but you
knew
episode 7 was abaco everything else
coming forward has additional ones but i
have to say completely biased but space
bear is the best one but it just made me
so happy because that panda logo was
like every time I saw that on official
stuff it just made me so happy
like on I think officially printed
budgets and stuff to see that dumb
little panda and his helmet up in the
corner
it's like the story that I don't know
this is true but that terry gilliam
named his production company for one of
his films new productions just so the
lawyers would have to write it going on
well maybe we can look forward to some
space bear merchandise and celebration
next year without going to be amazing
but on that topic because you know this
is the in many ways it's the road one
celebration in garrison and a great
spotlight moment on this stage to tell
the world about his movie next year
I think that's going to be your time to
have a big showcase moment and it also
happens to be the 40th anniversary of
Star Wars so
so what I'm saying is what we expect you
know you're going to be in orlando
orange
I think of that I think will be there ok
i'm looking forward to it and I am
by the way this is kind of like the
first time I'm coming out and kind of
talking about this thing that we've been
doing and I was very nervous about to
come out here but just what seeing all
you guys and seeing just the I don't
know the warmth and the yeah yeah I did
I had really looking forward to the to
the next year and a half i'm really
looking forward to showing you guys more
and more what we got and I think we're
all going to have a really good time
together
would anyone be interested any fans of
fn-2187
now when we started this panel actually
had carrion Kathy talk about ryan when
Ryan wasn't here so that we wouldn't
embarrass him but now that he's out here
feel free to embarrass what we was it
like to work with ryan Johnson as your
director
no Ryan is also Ryan's awesome I always
like to say that he's doing it indie
movie with in a studio franchise the
characters have been pushing their new
direction in a very cool way and we're
having fun
I haven't really really good fun this is
true yeah it's pointless
let me let me let me let me do it thank
you got one right here now you want to
find out some spoilers i'm not going to
do that but i do want to address
something here without spoilers for
people who are deeply concerned about
Finn because when we left him he was in
a coma so can you assure us you actually
walk around and talk and move and do
something in that episode 8 or mmm yeah
things ok that's what I'm just trying to
get we did at some point joke that it
would be great to just have him being
too , for the whole night just keep
coming back to him it's just like the
silence and other slightly his mother's
something with it but that the story is
very very interested in the end up on
this earth before so it's very very
interested to just keep it kind of like
secret
oh absolutely absolutely but in terms of
the process the production I mean how
did you how did this shoot compared to
to the force awakens because the force
awakens was your first exposure of being
a star wars fan on the Star Wars step
idea that any of that kind of I mean
that event was my a han solo action
figure that I had from episode 7 yeah I
remember that
guys there's more signatures on it it is
just get better as the start was fired
I get to come into work and enjoy my
time with you know new members of cost
and obviously Ryan's great with a new
energy in a new take on honest not a
real story and and it feels like Star
Wars but then at the same time we have a
new director to lead us in the interest
in puff so it's really really fun and
having fun
so how much has your life changed now
that you know you are Finn star star
wars
I mean I just got back from Tesco's so
and no seriously seriously and and I no
one bothered me but you know it's it's
it's been it's been fun it's strange to
see all these figures still is something
that had been taken in you know a man
you playin han Solo man
damn that
it's crazy it's crazy it's crazy but
it's it's it's been great and the star
wars fans have been amazing it's like
the best find them to be apart
it's really cool so any words of advice
for all the new no man i really go home
but you know you're gonna be fine to me
you got that charm stuff down don't you
and he's smiling just like her
this is great now it's gonna be fun very
very good experience man obviously your
great head on you so you enjoy the right
to short
yeah
oh man you know one one person that I
met briefly a nice a nice day here
because I've been here for a while and
you can talk about it briefly because I
i really enjoyed meeting with was Kelly
Marie tran and and this is her first big
movie and it's a big star wars movie and
and you know you two of you have worked
with her if you could talk about working
with her and I am so excited for you
guys to meet Kelly and this is a the
invisible in in good time and and I
think
yeah it did I don't know how that i want
to say too much also because I want her
to build a come out and present herself
properly down the line but she's really
something special man she is really
something spend a lot of great energy
and a great addition to our star wars
family
this is a family that keeps growing
looking we've got the prequel trilogy
represented here with with ryan and john
and we've got the new standalone
programs represented here with crystal
and alden and and it just feels like we
need we need to represent the classic
trilogy here don't we be we need to
really fill out this family portrait
so without further ado please welcome
our camel and Carrie Fisher
yeah
I
haha
yeah
you know it's moving in a way cuz you
can tell you're part of people's
childhoods and it's like this palpable
exuberance I mean it is sometimes I just
get lightheaded with it i have to think
of something else or just fake get away
seriously I know you do
ithaca but really thank you so much i
can't tell you you come through the line
and I'm really tired but uh it's it's
it's something that just gives me a
charge like I can't explain i'm so
grateful for it
character what he said
I over hell he ain't heavy he's my
brother
and it is it is like what if it's like
family and the great thing about the
movie is that those of you that have
children that have impregnated people i
could take those signing humans and take
them to these movies see which
characters they respond to and all that
stuff is so awesome and you bring little
tiny tiny just more people in
Princess Leia outfits which I appreciate
because i think that you swallow those
outfits so the baby doesn't come out
dude
which would be so embarrassing so it's
trust
it's a fantastic thing and it's time I
never heard that
serie b is what a very interesting
theories and you have to think about
that is why we're very sibling it's very
deep
thank you fit we picked fighting back I
like that
we got it already activated lights on
lovely quote yeah
what is the matter with you but you
can't take me anywhere
when I brought you here are you
it was and I promised you I'd be on my
best behavior you know it's something
people say are you guys really like
brothers and sisters I said yeah we
fight all the time we were not speaking
to each other for years and it's on now
we're going to speak to each other when
you have a shared experience and darn it
I will defend her with my life but she
still drives me quite a date
it's a dirty job but someone's gotta do
it
it is my doodriver crazy will
demonstrate that throughout the eve
dollar you're a dim exasperatingly woman
that was actually Thornton Wilder's
first title
the working title for merchant of
Yonkers was a damn exasperated I was
hoping you'd bring that I have happened
eventually became hello dolly
see i have i'm a font of yes so many
stories like that and that is what star
wars is about it absolutely this is
actually the new sheep will I know what
I think that giving that away still your
guards
well then you sequel is about a lot of
stuff with Hello Dolly
yes that's right yeah hello Gary you
better and I always make sure Gary gets
apart it leads to the next one
I got my cousin that there are now two
all of this universe stars will do is
out which are no dogs are there
there should be little credit come on it
should be we can make that happen we
have the power to you guys
there are you have pets in space right
all right that's my contribution
when we and we love you for it brian is
this is a snapshot into what your
production experience was like it will
talk to Colin, talk to Colin, it was
all it was all this and more and
casting
I can't thank you all enough for coming
and saying hi and and wrapping up this
celebration and with such a memorable
way this is the star wars family
we're going to take some family
portraits here before we wrap and i want
to remind everyone that the closing
ceremonies are happening here work Davis
has going to come out and recap with
amazing past three days
this has been all of us we're going to
see you in orlando where we're going to
be able to talk about star wars episode
8 and the untitled han solo star wars
movie
please join me and thanking these
amazing Danner
yeah